We're on problem 17.
The sum of three consecutive
odd integers is 111.
That's what they tell
us at the top.
I won't write that.
If n represents the least of the
three integers, which of
the following equations
represents
the statement above?
So n is the least of the
three integers, so
let's say that's n.
So it's the least of three
consecutive odd integers.
So what's the next odd
integer going to be?
It's not going to be n plus 1,
because n plus 1 is going to
be an even integer, right?
If this was 3 then the next odd
integer's going to be 5,
which is going to be n plus 2.
And then the next one above that
is going to be n plus 4.
And you can try it out.
Let's say that n was 3, and
this is 5, and this is 7.
That's three consecutive
odd integers.
And they're telling us
that the sum is 111.
So the sum is 111.
What's the sum of these
three terms?
Well, you add up
the three n's.
n plus n plus n is 3n.
And then 2 plus 4, 3n plus 6.
And that's going to
be equal to 111.
And that is choice D.
Maybe I just confused you
how I wrote this.
All I did is I said that's the
same thing as n plus n plus 2
plus n plus 4, which is
equal to 3n plus 6.
Next problem.
Problem 8.
And they do this arc.
It looks something like that.
It actually looks better
than what I just drew,
but you get the point.
So there's like a distance of 2,
and then there's a distance
of b, it looks like.
So it's 2 then b then 2 then
b then 2 then b again.
The figure above shows part
of a circle whose
circumference is 45.
So the circumference of
the circle is 45.
If arcs of length 2 and length b
continue to alternate around
the entire circle, so this is
just part of the circle and
they just keep going
around the circle.
They just keep going around the
circle so that there are
18 arcs of each length.
What is the degree measure of
each of the arcs of length b?
So they say there's 18
arcs of each length.
They say that there are 18 of
these arcs of lengths 2, and
there's 18 of these b segments
because they're saying this
is-- well, they drew
this as part of the
whole circle, right?
So that means that if the entire
circumference is 45,
but in terms of 2's and b's, we
know that there's 18 2's ,
so it's 18 times 2.
And then we also know that there
are 18 b's, plus 18b.
This is another way of writing
the circumference of the
circle. because they say that
the circumference is made of
18 of these arcs and 18 of these
b arcs here, so this is
also equal to the circumference
of the circle,
which they told us is 45.
Now let's see, this is 36.
18 times 2 plus 18b
is equal to 45.
Subtract 36 from both sides.
You get 18b is equal to 9.
b is equal to 9/18, which
is equal to 1/2.
Now what are they asking?
What is the degree measure of
each of the arcs of length b?
So we know that each b is 1/2.
And actually, you know what?
We could have gone
to this step.
We could have said that 18 b's--
well, no, actually, this
is-- each b is of length
1/2, right?
So what fraction is that of
the entire circumference?
This length right here is 1/2.
That's what we just
solved, right?
You saying there's going to be
18 b's and 18 arcs of length 2
and they all add up to 45.
We solve for b.
It's 1/2.
We want to figure out what's
the degree measure.
So to figure out the degree
measure, we say, well, 1/2 is
to the circumference of the
entire circle, which is 45, is
equal to the degree measure over
the total degrees in the
entire circle, because the
fraction in terms of the
circumference is the same thing
it's going to be in
terms of degrees as a fraction
of 360 degrees.
Why?
Because there's 360 degrees
in the circle.
So let's cross-multiply this.
1/2 times 360 degrees, so you
get 180 degrees-- that's 1/2
times 360-- is equal to 45x.
So x is equal to 180
divided by 45.
And what's 180 divided by 45?
Let's see, 40 goes into 160,
it's 4 times, right?
x is equal to 4.
4 times 45, right?
So x is equal to 4 degrees.
And that's choice A.
That also makes sense
intuitively.
4 degrees is a very small amount
of degrees, so that
makes sense if you were
going from the center.
I know what I just drew just
probably confused you.
Hopefully, you get the idea.
Figure out how long the b's
are and then what fraction
that is of the entire
circumference and then that's
what fraction it is
of 360 degrees.
Problem 19.
The cost of maintenance on
an automobile increases
each year by 10%.
And Andrew paid $300 this year
for maintenance on his
automobile.
Fine.
If the cost c for maintenance on
Andrew's automobile n years
from now is given by the
function, so c of n is equal
to 300x to the n, what
is the value of x?
So they say every year the
cost increases by 10%.
So what does it mean
to increase by 10%.
Let me say the cost in year 1,
let's say the cost in year 1
is going to be-- what's
the cost in year 2?
It's going to be the cost of
year 1 increased by 10%.
So plus 0.1 times the cost in
year 1, which is equal to 1.1
times the cost in year 1.
The cost in year 3 is equal to
1.1 times the cost in year 2,
which is the same
thing as what?
1.1 times the cost of year
2, which is this.
1.1 times 1.1, cost of year
1, which is the same
thing as 1.1 squared.
So every year that you go out,
you're essentially just taking
1.1 to that power of how many
years you're going out.
Actually, I should probably make
this cost of year 0, make
this cost of year 1, 0, 0, 0.
This is probably confusing you,
but cost of year 2, so
then the exponents at least
match up: 1 and then 0.
Then the exponents match up.
The cost of year 2 is 1.1
squared times cost of year 0.
So as you can see, all we're
doing when we're doing this,
this is kind of an exponential
growth problem.
But they're just saying
what is this base?
But when you increase something
by 10%, you're
essentially multiplying
it by 1., so
that's all they're asking.
So that's choice C.
Next problem.
They drew this parallelogram,
which I have not drawn well.
It gets the point.
A, B, C, D.
If the five line segments in
the figure above are all
congruent-- OK, so the five
lines, these are all
congruent, so they're all
equal to each other.
all of those sides, what
is the ratio of the
length of AC, not drawn?
So they want to know AC,
so that's this length.
They want to know
AC to length BD.
All right.
So all of those lines
are congruent.
You know what?
Let's just pick a number.
That's what I find to
be easiest when
they tell us it all.
So let's just say that this
is 1, this is 1, this
is 1, this is 1.
This whole thing is
going to be 1.
So how long is this and this?
This will bisect this
line, right?
I think we know that about
parallelograms that the two
lines bisect each other,
the two diagonals.
So this is going to be 1/2, and
this is going to be 1/2.
And there's also something
else we know.
We know that this is 60 degrees,
this is 60 degrees,
that this whole angle is 60
degrees, this whole angle is
60 degrees.
And how do we know that?
Before we drew the green line,
we knew that both of those
triangles are equilateral
triangles.
So if this whole angle was 60
degrees, then this angle right
here is going to
be 30 degrees.
And I think you see where
I'm going with this.
This is a 30-60-90 triangle
where this is 1-- that's the
hypotenuse-- this is 1/2.
And then what is the side
opposite the 60-degree side,
which is this?
The square root of 3 times
this side right here.
The square root of 3/2.
And so would this one.
This one would also be
square root of 3/2.
I know maybe it's a
little confusing.
Actually, I'm about to run out
of time, so I will continue
this in the next video.